for this exhibition on sustainability
we approach it like how we approach the
rest of our projects to do things in a
way that has not been done before
we are always looking for the power of
surprise in the case of the not so
convenience store
we are taking a familiar institution the
everywhere convenience store
and turning it on is hit this makes
people do a double take
immediately arousing their curiosity and
drawing them in
once inside our tweeze on the
convenience store allows us to share the
sustainability message in an engaging
and non-preachy way
we all love convenience but the not so
convenient truth is that there is a
price to this convenience
and is being paid by the earth instead
of regular price tags
ours spell out the price of convenience
in terms of the negative environmental
effects resulting from our wasteful
habits and mindset
this is just one example of how we weave
in educational elements while staying
through to the guise of a convenience
store
more importantly the not so convenient
store breaks down the big theme of
sustainability into small achievable
actions
each product in a store is a concrete
step everyone can take towards a more
sustainable lifestyle
we are able to strike a balance with the
not so convenient store
whose cheeky twist is designed to drive
home the message
rather than detract from it we had more
than 12 thousands visitors
across the two editions and the novel
form of our exhibition
caught the attention of news outlets
such as cna and today
there was healthy chatter on social
media too including someone from croatia
who wrote idol of one here in zagreb
so it was really nice to see our idea
resonating with people across the globe
we truly believe design can be a tool
for good
and we are happy to have been able to
use it to make the topic
of sustainability more accessible for
everyone
you don't need to be a hero so bring
your waste
down to zero find out more at the not so
convenience store